well we've got some clouds over the
mountains and what a beautiful shot as
we look out off to the west over red
rock over the spring mountains we're
expecting thunderstorms there again so
we're looking west but just to the left
there to the southwest just want to call
your attention to the evening sky here
as we get into the weekend and early
next week skies should be clearing out
overnight and in the evening hours if
you look in the southwest after right
around dusk after sunset you should see
venus and the moon setting up together
as that each evening as we get into the
weekend the moon will get a little
higher above venus but a really
beautiful sight especially if we have
clear skies and that should be happening
at least into saturday night and sunday
night all right kiddos it is a warm and
humid start to the day mid 80s out there
right now we've been in the 80s around
the valley and 104 for the afternoon
still with a slight chance of
thunderstorms and especially up over the
mountains we've got that monsoon
moisture in place and there's been quite
a bit of rain up into california oregon
that's been great news but there's also
been a lot of lightning associated with
these storms
in the sierras too so we're going to
really follow up in case of fire starts
from those lightning strikes there
otherwise across the other side of the
country of course new york city going to
be a lot of
memorial happenings there for 9 11.
temperatures are going to be nice rain
showers have worked their way off the
coast should get into the 70s today and
tomorrow for 9 11. the southeast
recovering after the leftovers of mindy
and hurricane larry is out in the
atlantic headed for new finland but
we've got a lot of activity down here
around the yucatan peninsula there is an
area that is developing that could bring
a lot of flooding rain up to coastal
texas early next week and hurricane olaf
battering the southern tip of baja with
some strong hurricane force winds right
now could feed into some monsoon
moisture but i think that it is going to
be capped off as we have a system that
will move into the northwest bring us
some drier southwest winds once we get
into the weekend so we had some storm
cells around us yesterday check it out
centennial hills
love that rain oh it sounded good thank
you susan hill for sharing your video
with us even got a little bit of hail
according to susan up in that far
northwest valley neighborhood yesterday
afternoon it was brief but they did pick
up four hundredths of an inch of rain
the mountains will be the best place
this afternoon for that chance of storms
a slight chance for the valley and hot
again 104. south breezes today southwest
breezes tomorrow and that will help kind
of dry things out we stay very hot
we should have temps in the 90s yeah mid
90s no we'll stay in the triple digits
all through your eight day football